they may look like big brand name sweets
but look closer and you'll see subtle
differences in packaging but big
differences in what they contain these
illegal Suites have substances like
cannabis in them and police say they're
ending up in the hands of children these
Suites are widely promoted and sold
online they appear virtually everywhere
Sky News found them on all major social
media platforms including Instagram Tick
Tock and Facebook and on Facebook alone
when we search the term Edibles on
marketplace around a third of the
results that came up contain drugs it's
something that's causing problems for
most police forces around the country
police in the East and southeast of
England have shared exclusive
information with us suggesting that its
boys and girls consuming cannabis
Edibles these boys and girls tend to be
of secondary school age and of people
they've arrested a third were under the
age of 18. these illegal Suites contain
something called THC the ingredient in
cannabis which gives the user a high for
children's side effects from it can be
incredibly harmful cannabis damages mood
memory and motivation
now that's a terrible damage of effect
in young children to damage their mood
memory and motivation and the other
thing about cannabis is that it's a
gateway drug
it's sold in county lines and the same
people are selling acid ecstasy Like
Cocaine heroin there's also concern that
consumption of these illegal sweets is
Rising one of the things we know is that
this sale um is on the increase
um it seems to be more and more of them
coming onto the market
um I think one of the things we are
aware of is that there's been some
recent hospitalizations of children
who've been consuming these projects
meta who own Instagram Facebook and
WhatsApp said they proactively removed
98 of this content in the last quarter
and that they're working with police and
youth organizations to further improve
their moderation I shizar hid Sky News